各位许博科技教师的观众朋友大家好我是许博
今天是星期四晚上
我们科技问答的时间
喜欢我们的节目
记得替我们按赞订阅分享
那节目刚开始的时候呢
我们还是要再强调一次
许博所有的YouTube Facebook跟LINE社群平台
都不会和大家私下谈论个股的股价
更不会和大家推荐个股投资
如果大家收到任何陌生人传送讯息
关心股票操作或者推荐个股
那个都是大片集团
请大家不用客气替我检举它
请大家告诉大家
感谢大家的协助
那首先呢我们来看一下
刚刚有网友留了眼
这个看起来没有要问问题
不过呢可以跟大家分享一下
第一个呢讲到这个三星最新宣布
量产这个PCIe 6.0的SSD固态硬碟机
那这边提到这个产品的定位很清晰
是三星专门为英伟达下一代VeraRubin AI
算力平台深度定制的套件
企业级的储存硬碟
这个就是所谓的企业级的固态硬碟机
各位知道VeraRubin它本身可以做训练跟推论
特别是推论的时候需要大量的记忆体
所以这边我觉得它讲的应该是专门设计给
VeraRubin伺服器里面
有一个储存伺服器使用的固态硬碟剂
那再来这个网友问到
7月6号亚培锡科技跟中国石油
兰州石化联合启动千顿级的乙锡
锡听中的这个四季化
这个卫星化学连云港
25万顿级的乙锡
这个乙锡或者锡类的东西
这边特别提到
2025年底要投产
那中石化茂名5万吨
LAO
这个基本上指的就是C类的
有机化合物
事实上C类的有机化合物是聚合物的原料
那他算是上游的原料
所以石油化学工业上游非常重要的原材料
那各位知道这个
其实石油化学工业
这个就是以前的台数
各位知道台塑集团以前曾经很赚钱
后来中国大陆开始建设这种基础工业
也就是石油化学的基础工业
各位知道大陆在盖这种石油化学
都是非常非常庞大的计划
所以非常可怕
产能一开出来之后
石油化学工业相关的原料就变得非常辛苦
很难做
这个就是台塑世保最近很辛苦的原因
这个基础工业坦白说非常的重要
那再来就是7月7号北京大学电子学院
梁学磊教授团队成功研发出
基于全奈米碳管的互补厂销电晶体
这个用奈米碳管做电晶体
其实之前有很多科学家都做过
那当然这个还是要去看一下
它实际上的元件跟过去的人做的有什么差别
这是数位逻辑电路
那这种CFAT是透过垂直堆叠N型跟P型的长销电晶体
一般我们讲CFAT就是NMOS在上面
PMOS在下面
或者导过来
基本上就是一个在上一个在下这种立体堆叠
那看起来它应该是用奈米碳管去做这样的堆叠
那他是被国际元件跟系统路线图
列为2奈米以下技术节点的关键元件
事实上2奈米以下用这个CFAT
但是不是用奈米碳管
所以其实是不需要奈米碳管
那他这边写预计2032年商业化
但是我说实话
因为奈米碳管这个东西
我以前做研究的时候
很多实验室都在做
但这个东西很难商业化
就是很难量产
CFET确实是两奈米以下的
制程路线
但是
跟奈米碳管没有关系
理论上当然可以用奈米碳管做
台积电也曾经发表过奈米碳管做的数位逻辑电路
但是不是CFET
不过这个奈米碳管要量产困难很高
主要就是那个要控制奈米碳管
在细晶圆表面
非常密集的排列
这个难度非常高
所以我想还是要回头来看CFAT就好了
那再来2026年的7月9号
北京那场超节点
与这应该是GIGAWA级的AIDC
这个指的技术论坛
华为联合中国移动百度
京东云还有中国电研院等等
20多家产业链提出
OpenNPO项目
这个NPO应该是指进风装光学吧
我在猜啦
总之现在大陆就是联合自己的厂商
一起来做这个AI相关的技术开发
那蚂蚁林波
这都大陆的新闻
科技宣布开源
这个Limboot Video
全球首个基于混合专家模型
就是把不同的
各位知道模型是资料的规则
那不同的资料
有不同的规则
那混合专家模型指的就是
把好几种
各位知道这个人工智慧
要训练出一个
大一统的模型非常困难
所以后来他们干脆就
不同的专业用不同的模型
那混合起来使用
面向具有
聚生智慧的开源
视讯生成基础模型
这个就是MOE
取代传统的这个架构
在扩大模型
容量同时可以控制推理成本
那它呢是使用30个B
就是300亿个参数的模型
生成的时候呢
只要启动大概30亿就够了
相较于同等参数规模的架构
拥有三倍的推理效率
这个确实大陆在人工智慧模型
这一块做得很快啦
其实跟美国互相竞争
无界动力宣布旗下第二代的机器人K15
通过欧盟合规准入
成为首个获得工业级全域CE认证
就是欧洲欧盟的认证的巨声智慧机器人
同时无界动力全球近1亿美元的国内外订单也全面交互
相关计划持续推进
目前首批K15机器人正式发往欧洲
其实大陆的机器人也都做得很快
那我们来看一下有没有照片给大家看一下
各位看到就是这个
这个可能还是做一些辅助吧
再来是科创版日报
这个原籍维科技
二维半导体
工程化示范
全线贯通
在上海浦东的新区川
沙新镇
宏图大楼举办
这看起来是
二维半导体
但是没有特别说是哪一种二维半导体
那这边又问到了
韩国现在要发射几百个卫星做星链
台湾不跟进没关系吗
这个问题问得好
这个坦白说
这个韩国有钱
那低轨道卫星没有那么简单
主要是因为这个低轨道卫星
大概两个小时到地球一圈
换句话说它不是同步卫星
它不会固定在上空的某一点
所以你要把台湾覆盖起来
如果是用地轨道卫星的话
你要用很多颗
所以基本上要有实力跟财力
去发射这么多的卫星才行
那我曾经跟太空中心的专家讨论过
好像如果要把台湾
确保用地轨道卫星
而且每两个小时绕地球一圈又要确保通讯不中断各位想想看兩個小時繞一圈你從地平線看到這個低尾道衛星
一直到它從地平線消失的
另一端大概只有10分鐘
換句話說每10分鐘就要換一顆
那你看看一天有幾個10分鐘
然後你要確保
這個24小時通訊不中斷
所以需要至少發射好幾百顆
那问题是要发射几百颗卫星
台湾又没有能力自己发射
所以要送去给人家发射
这个需要钱
那就算真的做到几百颗卫星
让台湾使用地轨道卫星不会中断
那问题来了
这个卫星一颗
其实那个容量也没多少
所以你也不够给全台湾人用
所以恐怕只能紧急的时候
特殊的人才能用
那在这种状况下
这样的卫星其实就比较辛苦
所以即使呢要做
这样的低轨道卫星
一者是谁要出钱
二者是呢
你一般企业做的话呢
也很难赚钱
一般平常也不会有人用
就算可以用呢
他的平关也不够
那如果要政府做呢
这恐怕要少很多钱
那政府也没有这种预算
所以难就难在这里
那再来网友问到
韩国有新闻说
常新存储在试验一条产线
用间接低润绕开EUV
这跟套律律是一样的原理吗
这个我没有特别研究
我可能要查一下资料
不过呢
其实低润不需要EUV
各位知道那个
低润是非常先进的制程
才有在用EUV
确实有人用
但是事实上
不用做那么先进的低润
其实不需要用到极止外光了
所以
应该可以用其他的方法来
绕开这个EUV
这个很有可能是用先进封装
对啊晶圆对晶圆混合建核
简单的说就是不用EUV去缩小
记忆体他直接呢
用混合建核的方式把记忆体堆叠
这样确实就可以增加密度
这个有点类似用HBM的堆叠方式
但是这个当然是成本的问题
我要做个结论
美国一直想要去封锁中国这些生产设备
但实际上三不转路转
我昨天就有看到华为的淘定律
又发表了Version 2
我还在收集资料
当然目前还没有看到晶片
但是根据华为内部发表的测试报告
其实上一次这个淘定律
预计2026年要发表的这个
手机处理器晶片
看起来他们真的做出来了
所以真的不要再笑人家华为
这个掏定律是骗人的
我跟各位说那是真的
只是说到底能做到多好
这个还不确定
良率做的好不好
这个也不确定
但是掏定律是真的有用
不是没有用
那再来网友问到
对未来是否以玻璃为主的材料之一
我们台场是否
在往康宁所带的研发方向前进
因为虽然说短期内可以跟FAU共除
但是未来的跟进似乎更重要
你这边讲的应该是
康宁最近发表的那个glass bridge
那个实际上呢
是可以取代FAU的一种方法
那我们给大家看一下这个东西
讲到玻璃
各位真的不要小看康宁
他真的是玻璃的王者
那我们来看一下这个东西
实际上它就是把玻璃的表面
制作出细细一条一条的光波导
各位记得把这个金属离子
渗透到玻璃里面
就会产生折射力大的区域
那折射力大的一条一条就是光波导
然后利用这两个金属来精准的定位
然后再做插拔
所以给各位看一下这个影片
这个影片其实介绍的非常详细
这是一个
CPU共同封装光学
那各位看这是机架里面的一台交换机
那各位看这个交换机中间这个是交换晶片
这个黑色的就是光子晶片
所以这个是电这个是电转光
然后各位有没有看到透过这个
Glass Bridge Connector
上面有一条一条的就是光波导
这两个金属可以很精准的把这个
接頭接進來
然後這邊總共有16條光纖
對著16條波島
有沒有看到這個黑色
細細的這個就是波島
就是折射率大的區域
有沒有看到光纖的光
那就透過這個波島直接送進這個光子晶片
所以這個就是那個連接的單元
然後這個是光纖
所以每一條都16條光纖
總共16個排線
每一個排線16條光線
所以總共16乘16條光線
所以這個是交換晶片
這個光子晶片
這個就是那個光的連接器
確實你用它這個解決方案
實際上不需要FAU也可以
所以未來的狀況會怎麼樣
我覺得還需要觀察
簡單的說這個FAU
短期内呢是还是必须用
主要是因为台积电的CPO已经要量产
就是KOOB
那这个康宁这个东西推出来的比较晚
所以台积电不太可能立刻用
所以我认为台积电的
这一代跟下一代产品
应该还是用传统的FAU
那未来有没有可能用康宁
那就要看台积电最后跟康宁怎么合作
这个我不清楚
还要看
还要观察
那再来讲到大陆这边的
淘定律封装和台积电封装
本质上有差别吗
有哦
这个我介绍过淘定律
我们的影片呢
有一部专门讲淘定律
讲得非常的详细
那个连大陆都有很多网友
直接把那个影片呢
就搬到这个大陆的平台上
所以各位有兴趣的话呢
可以看一下
这个淘定律呢
这一部讲得非常详细
所以你有兴趣的话看一下
那总之呢这个华为呢
因为没有极致外光的技术
所以他必须想办法让这一个时间延迟缩短
那他们想到的方法呢
就是做逻辑折叠
也就是把原来应该在同一个晶片上的元件呢
把它变成上下两个晶片去拉线
那这样子就缩短线的距离
那根据华为前几天发表的文章
他们下半年要量产的
这一个淘定律的晶片呢
看起来那个数字表现得还不错
所以他们这个技术是有用的
不是没有用
所以算是很厉害了
只是说真正测试的结果如何
这个其实等晶片量产之后
跑分之后就知道
这个后面马上下半年就会有答案
再来这边网友问到
脉冲式核融合发电Helion
或准建造目标在2028年稳定对外供电
我们终于要有核荣核发电厂了吗
好吧我研究一下看这个东西是不是可行
我个人认为应该没有那么快
2028年
两年呢不太可能
那再来网友问到
台湾有本土的气体探测公司吗
以及气体感测器的技术
坦白说台湾好像比较少这一类的公司
我记得曾经拜访过
在新竹有一家做电子笔的公司
台湾可能有一定也量不大
做的可能不多
所以很少听过
再来网友问到
台湾目前量子科技
比较声称有着力的
好像是人保红埃广达
台积电未来可能会如何衔接
这个我不知道
因为目前确实人保好像是用投资的方式广达也是鸿海也是投资国内的一些实验室那到底做到什么程度了
我觉得都还要观察
这个跟国外都有很大的落差
跟大陆也有很大的落差
那另外台积电未来
坦白说
不要再说台积电有做量子电脑
只是没有公布而已
没有这回事
台积电如果有做的话
你去查他的专利就知道
你一查就知道台积电没有什么量子电脑的专利
换句话说
他光是设厂都已经忙不完了
根本没有耐心时间去搞那个量子电脑
那我认为未来如何衔接
这个我之前的影片介绍过
台积电呢在美国设研发中心
那最有可能的做法就是在美国的研发中心
跟美国当地的实验室或研究机构合作
现在自己做来不及了
我跟各位说台积电量子电脑的技术落后
很多很多
现在自己才开始做
我认为是根本不用做
来不及了
唯一的可能就是利用台积电制造的优势
去跟美国的实验室或研究机构合作
那么共同来开发量产的技术
因为量子电脑现在遇到的问题
很多都是工程问题
也就是理论上可行
但是工程上这个元件可能做不出来
或者良率很低或者困难很高
那这种良率困难自成要解决
这个就是台积电的强项
所以我个人会认为台积电切入的方法
应该是用合作的方式
所以台积电的美国研发中心
这个量子电脑应该是他们一定会做的
那我想我可以想到的事情
他们一定会想到
因为台积电的人其实都非常的优秀
也非常的聪明
我们拭目以待
再来网友问到康宁会取代FAU吗
波罗威会受影响吗
如果刚刚有解释
这个短期内不会
我认为这一代是一定不会
因为没那么快
至少下一代应该也还是
不至于用康宁的东西
但是再来很可能
这个看康宁跟台积电
或其他厂商怎么合作
再来网友问到这个Hammer储存技术
这个是那个Seagat的硬碟机
使用的技术
它可以让那个储存密度再提高
就是让那个储存的单元再缩小
是可以取代目前 SSD 的光阳科把材有护成合吗
这是两件事
这个Hammer不会取代 SSD
这个Hammer它是硬碟机
SSD是固态硬碟
那么根据目前的发展
坦白说这个硬碟机还是有一些限制
譬如说它的速度
因为它是机械装置
所以他用马达去控制池头去读写资料
这个还是需要时间
所以硬碟机的速度还是比较慢
那他容量虽然比较高
但是而且他成本会比较低
但是因为速度慢
所以这个在实物应用上
确实在人工智慧的伺服器
还是会有一席之地
但是呢SSD他的特色也很明显
就是速度快
那各位发现
以可靠度来说是
Hammer技术可靠度更高
这种SSD是电子元界
它的可靠度会比较低
可是它因为速度快
所以它还是有它的市场
所以不会取代
我认为会共存
观众科的把财是有护城额的吗
应该算有吧
因为它比较特别是回收废把财
然后存化提炼在生产
我个人认为算是有特色
但是把财其实也有其他的供应商
我想就是互相竞争
大概是这样子
再来问有问到最近特斯拉又发生电池瘟疫的问题
很久之前Gogoro也发生好像是特斯拉刀片电池
磷酸铃铁
Gogoro是三元铃电池
我不确定
这个特斯拉的电池有三元铃电池
也有磷酸铃铁
那不确定他发生问题的是哪一种电池
Model Y
大电池故障
这一波的是比亚迪的刀片电池
这有可能啊
各位知道刀片电池
其实就是把那个锂电池
本来要包好多层的外壳
然后把它变成减少这些外壳
那就可以减轻重量提高能量密度
但是我跟各位说
这个刀片电池那个安全性肯定
没有原来的设计高了
有一好没两好
所以用比亚迪的电池
确实可能风险高一些
不知道
这个看起来应该是大陆在出售的
这个特斯拉电动车
这个跟狗狗楼应该是不一样的问题
但是跟大陆当地的一些
比亚迪相关的电动车可能是类似
我不确定
比亚迪的电动车卖很久了
好像也没什么问题
刀片电池虽然安全性可能会比原来的设计差一些
但是也已经卖那么多年了
应该也该有的问题都解决了
再来干模光组是用先进封装吗
不需要因为干模光组通常是先进制程在用的
一般我们的光组都是用有机化合物
溶在溶剂里面
這種聚合物的這一種是濕的乾光組
乾的光組就是用
鍍膜的方式來做這個光組
光組就是阻擋層
擋這個光的
所以這一種東西通常是用在先進製程
那理論上當然可以用在先進封裝
只是說乾膜光組的
價格會比這個濕的光組還要貴
因為濕的光組是旋轉徒步的比較便宜
那先进封装那是微米等级的东西
不需要用到干磨光组
再来红镜的测试热处理方面
声称超越其他家一个世代
到4000瓦
这个很重要
因为人工智慧伺服器的功率非常高
所以呢
测试的时候需要做热处理
有否犯式改变的风险
真的会越来越高温吗
对啊会越来越高温
因为功率越来越高
另外此类热处理上推进的工艺难度非常高
我认为没有非常高
就是有难度但是没有非常高
当然你的功率越高
整个测试需要的环境就越复杂
难度确实越高
但是你要说它非常高
我觉得很难这么说
我觉得宏进的优势是在于
它耕耘了十几年
所以呢他跟相关的厂商配合的非常密切
你现在想要取代他非常困难
倒不是这个技术困难度有多高
而是你要怎么去说服客户换别的方案
这个我觉得难度很高
这种是十几年培养下来的这种信任度
这个我觉得最难的是这里
然后你要取代他
你可能要花好几年的时间
然后等到你好不容易
说服客户要取代他的
这个市场搞不好已经不如预期了
所以这个我觉得是宏记现在最大的优势
再来日月光的先进封装大量扩厂
是不是可以理解成光阳科把财也会被大量使用
我觉得两件事
这个光阳科的把财
他们主要是想要做制成方面的
不是封装方面的
那当然这个封装里面也可能会用到见度
因为它涨那个总指程也是见度
所以把财的需求量确实会增加
所以你这样讲感觉好像也没错
因为封装有一部分制程需要用到见度
但是是不是观光科我不确定
这个可能要再确认一下
Intel的18a跟EMIP封装会超车台阶吗
不会
这个Intel的18a
它实测出来的数字
其实前一代大概是跟3奈米台积电差不多那我认为台积电在先进制程这一块还是领先Intel一段时间
EMIB的封装
类似于台积电COWAS系列的封装
很难说Intel超超车啦但是
差距会缩小是真的
这个大陆的同创普论
从材料供应商变成国产高端半导体材料突破的代表公司
公司主要做超高纯度的金属材料高纯度的金属材料研发生产销售
4n5 6n的坦
6n的铝 7n的铜
5n的蒙
n就是几个9
0.99999
就是纯度非常高的这个金属生产
各位要知道这个金属冶炼技术
中国大陆是非常先进的
各位知道那个
不只是矿产很多在大陆
连这个冶炼技术坦白说都做得非常好
这是事实
核心产品关键指标达到国际先进水准
对啊
某些产品可以用在先进制程
这有可能
是啊
坦试用来做半导体的什么
那很多啊
那个坦
那个我记得好像
导电层还是界电层里面有用到一些
什么氧化坦
然后用到一些坦的化合物
不是只有坦
在金属导线的部分主要是铜
但是在某些不同结构的地方
可能会用一些不同的元素成分
用量都不大一点点
但是纯度要求很高
请问曲波细光子都要使用零化音
这是因为零化音会发光
这个特别强调
零化音发光的波长是1.3微米跟1.55微米
这两个波长是光通讯用的波长
主要是因为在光纤里面
这两个波长的红外光
它的吸收率最低
所以可以传最远的距离
这就是为什么零化音是用来做发光元件
就是雷射
一定要用这个材料
还有其他材料可以取代吗
以雷射来说没有
雷射要发出这两个波长一定用零化音
那以光侦测器来说可以用零化音也可以用细折
那虽然细折可以取代零化音
但是以那个光侦测器的灵敏度
还有效率来说呢
这个细折还是比零化音差
所以零化音这个材料非常的重要
再来Intel下一代主流自强处理器
已经透过出货记录
平台将采用LGA
这个LGA是Intel
给CPU用的一种封装
它那个插槽
各位知道以前是PGA
后来变BGA
这个LGA是另外一种
1954个插槽
搭载NovaLACS架构的自强处理器
可以有28个核心
热射机功耗只有95W
这是Intel时隔多年推出
桌面级市场主流产品
对啊
Intel最近股价也很强
CPU的这个王者归来
这个CPU被吓杀
他讲的应该是股价
Kyber延期技术问题可以解决吗
这个我不知道是什么问题
但我有听说
各位Kyber伺服器就是刀锋伺服器
这个原来的这个伺服器呢
它的那个
ComputeTrade
就是运算托盘是水平的
那个叫Oberon
那Kyber是变成锤子一片一片的
其实就是刀锋伺服器的变形
那我不确定它发生什么问题
但我认为那个一定可以解决
反正就是延后而已
就找个理由把那个涨过头的CPU砍一砍
这个其实就是股市里面的高手在操作
FAU最难的部分是对准
康宁的玻璃桥
Galaxy Bridge号称可以自对准
那么FAU除了散热跟鲜盐
研究部分还有什么优势
没有没有什么优势
这个FAU不过就是一个把
光纤对准的东西
结果呢因为现在那个光纤
他通常是FAU加光纤然后用强力交封在一起
这样听说一条要卖100块美金
那各位知道这个
东西其实没有门槛那么高
但是呢却搞到一条100块美金
结果就造成做FAU的厂商股价被炒翻天
各位想想看一个没有很特别的东西
结果可以卖到100块美金
那会不会大家都想要做
所以我想FAU就是趁现在赶快出货
先捞一笔
等到拖个两三年之后
那个价格肯定会变价格战
所以要就要快
大概是这样
康宁会取到CPU吗
而这不一样
这个CPU是要用FAU
也可以用康宁桥
康宁桥有可能取代部分的FAU
但是我刚刚讲过了
至少我觉得要两年吧
所以短期内也没有办法取代
是因为台积电很多研发都已经做了
现在要换不可能
再来台湾稳定币要出来的
我们本土银行能不能借机转型
当然应该要发稳定币
只是我现在不确定台湾的稳定币
是要用公有链交易
还是用私有链交易
因为用公有链交易可以洗钱
那我不确定监管机关会同意吗
如果用私有链的话就没办法洗钱
但是私有链发的稳定币
币圈的人才不会要用
所以那种稳定币是没用的东西
我认为私有链的稳定币一定推不动
公有链的稳定币就可以推起来
但是可以洗钱
但是我不知道监管机关怎么想
把国内企业支付把握住
至少提高营收变成区域及银行吧
这个国内企业支付跟稳定币
没有什么关系
用不用稳定币都一样
这个稳定币基本就是
公有链交易的话
就可以跳过监管机关
换句话说
你把新台币换成稳定币之后
进到公有链
然后就可以流行通行全球
畅通无阻
那这个时候呢
爱怎么流通都可以
很方便确实是
那它的原因并不是因为什么
特别的原技术
主要只要是因为它工有链
所以它的帐就是寄在矿工电脑里
矿工是谁你也不认识
大家都不认识那是工有链
大概就是这样
那国内企业支付呢
用不用稳定币理论上都可以做得到
跟这个东西没有太大的关系
再来IT之家消息
斯特威发表5000万画素1微米的
高动态范围CMOS影像感测器
针对中高阶智慧型手机影像打造
采用22奈米的Stack制程流程
这个是大陆的公司吧
还好啦影像感测器
我觉得这个难不倒大陆的厂商吧
我再看看它有什么特别的地方
他这个看起来好像有一些比较特别的结构
有一些专利技术
技嘉科技正式发表
AI Top Atoms 4串连机构
群集架构展现地端人工智慧运算
这个就是所谓的边缘人工智慧
突破单机限制
资源大规模人工智慧科学运算负载
AI Top Atoms 4G串连集群
有效突破单机架构的限制
让企业资料不离境
换句话说就是
边缘运算
边缘云端
执行高机一体需求的工作任务
加速AI部署落地
这种边缘的人工智慧伺服器
这个技嘉没有什么问题
一定做得起来
好我们今天的节目到这边
大家对于各种科技有任何问题
欢迎大家发表在影片的下方
我们随时可以讨论
谢谢大家晚安
拜拜